six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number we are taking
calls that's what we're doing right now
and we're gonna go next to our caller
from the nine one nine area code caller
from nine one nine please identify
yourself what's your name where are you
calling from and what's on your mind
today nine one nine can you hear us
hmm first one today that hold music
again it's I think they just love to
hold me relax much that it puts people
to sleep yeah okay
let's go to eight five seven caller from
eight five seven are you there can you
hear me and where are you calling from
hey David are you doing my name is Chris
I can hear you and I'm from Everett
Massachusetts awesome where is Everett
anyway is that north of Boston yes it is
it's right by like Malden and Saugus
it's just a little suburb oh wait is
Everett where nightshift Brewing Company
is it's um I don't think so oh okay I
thought it was alright anyway Everett
Everett very good what's on your mind
today okay so I'm more of a conservative
person I was raised in a conservative
family but something I've noticed in the
past couple years so is that we kind of
live in a society where you kind of get
stuff catered to you whether it's Amazon
or whatever so you usually end up only
seeing things you like and I wondered if
you thought that was true Stu because on
the conservative side it seems like they
try to make everyone look like antifoam
members and on the liberal side
especially in like your hatred male
segments we see only the worst from both
sides so I wondered if you thought
bubble that people can live in is
affecting the political discord okay so
first of all just a correction I don't
know that hey treat male shows us the
worst of both sides I think hatred mail
shows us the worst of one particular
side but no that's the worst the
Republicans are on Fox News they show
and keep up right yeah I mean listen
whatever regardless of what anybody's
individual politics are it's hard to
deny that in the age of social network
algorithms and self selection of new
sources people are not in some kind of
echo chamber type of situation and I
will bump into people outside of my
circles for different reasons right and
they will be from a different place
politically and they have no idea about
some of what in my mind are just major
stories because of story selection bias
and you just see certain stories aren't
even being told on certain media outlets
people aren't even aware of what's going
on so they can't even really form an
opinion on it it's just as if it doesn't
exist so yeah echo chambers are a
problem I think if everybody had an
unlimited amount of media consumption
time they would go out of their way to
try to first start learning about a
story from as close to a no opinion
source as possible right whether it's
Reuters or whatever the case might be to
try to first get the facts and then find
individuals that you think are
respectable on both the left and right
and see if you're dealing with an issue
where the left and right are united and
if not sort of figure out what the two
perspectives are but you know most
people Kris don't really have the time
to do that and thus yeah there's a lot
of echo chamber stuff now the one part I
do want to take issue with you is it's
very easy to say hey the rights got this
on the left has that the left's got
their echo chamber and the rights got
their echo chamber but that starts going
in the direction of trumps there were
really fine people on both sides
including the side of the neo-nazis and
I think it's really important anytime to
do any analysis to figure out is it
really the same on both sides or not
okay yeah right sweet thank you for
answering my question I think the
internet presents their presence of the
all right makes people think it's bigger
than it is but thank you for answering
my question all right that's fair I
actually don't I don't disagree with
that Pat I think it's possible that in
broadly speaking the alt-right movement
in the u.s. is not nearly as big as the
Internet makes it seem I think that
that's fair that doesn't mean it's not a
problem or a vile movement but I think
it's not as big as the Internet makes it
seem they could just be speaking louder
but I've represented far
with the number of people that they have
possible yep absolutely
all right thanks to everybody who called
in let's go to a break coming up we have
three count them three really good
audience questions that will be
answering